Using traveling stitches to frame eyelets
can create a beautiful, decorative
stitch pattern for your knitting.
As machine knitters, because the purl side
faces us as we knit, this can
be a bit confusing at first.
This is one of those techniques
that you have to try it to get it.
The secret is to get a mental picture
of the effect from the knit side
or the finished side of the work.
To make the stitches travel,
we'll work a two-step transfer.
First, we'll identify
the traveling stitch.
Then transfer the stitch next to it,
doubling up the stitches.
Then move both stitches
to fill that emptied needle.
This transfer empties the eyelet needle.
Make sure you keep that eyelet
needle in work and knit two rows.
Next, identify  that traveling stitch
again by following your chart,
and you can also reach underneath and feel
the bulk of that traveling stitch.
Transfer the stitch next to it, doubling
up the stitches and emptying a needle.
Take both of those stitches and transfer
them to fill the emptied needle.
Moving these two stitches
empties the eyelet needle.
Make sure that that eyelet needle
remains in work and knit two rows.
You'll continue this
for the stitch pattern.
Now, you can also keep track
of the traveling stitch by needle number
by creating a chart.
Use Knitter's Graph paper and draw out
what you want your traveling
stitches to look like.
Your best bet is to try this on a swatch.
Once you take it off the machine,
the light bulb will come on and you can
get creative with positioning
traveling eyelets across your knitting.
Don't forget that these eyelets are going
to impact your stitch and row gauge,
so be sure to swatch in pattern.